Sometimes we have a go or a try.
Makes small mistakes and wants to cry.
Making mistakes is not sad.
Making mistakes is not bad.
Come on just have a go or a try.
Albert Einstein with his brilliant mind said,...
..."Anyone who has never made a mistake...
...has never tried anything new."
Learning from mistakes makes you great.
And guess what I'm going to tell you straight.
Forget mistakes and believe and see what you can achieve.
Learning from mistakes makes you great.
Richard Branson, a successful businessman said,...
..."You don't learn to walk by following the rules.
You learn by doing and by falling over."
Sometimes we have a go or a try.
Makes small mistakes and wants to cry.
Making mistakes is not sad.
Making mistakes is not bad.
Come on just have a go or a try.